hey guys it's dr. Berg here I'm going to
show you how to fix plantar fasciitis
it's the easiest thing to fix the way
that they teach us in school honestly is
it takes too long this is a shortcut
and you can try this on yourself or
friends and it will work very fast okay
but the thing you need to do first is
just rate the pain 10 being very severe
zero being no pain and then do the
procedure and then rewrite it and I want
you to put your comments below because I
want to know how much improvement that
this gave you okay so the first thing
you do is take a look at if plantar
fasciitis is some pain in the bottom of
your foot right here there's a fossa it
said it's a bunch of like a sheath of
collagen connective tissue that becomes
inflamed in the bottom of your foot and
by the way this technique can be used on
flat feet too the worst thing you can do
is to stretch the calf okay or massage
the bottom of the foot that will never
work that makes it worse because you're
going to be tearing things what we want
to do is want to stress the opposite we
want to press the toes going downward
and then relax stretch the toes down and
relax what you're doing is you're
stretching all the muscles on the top of
the foot the tendons and the shin
muscles right here called the anterior
tibialis so we want to stretch all these
muscles not the calf very important so
you do this about 10 times okay just
stretch it stretch it really good and
you can do the other side we're
stretching down this way okay I mean you
can do it up to 20 times now this is
difficult for you you could just go
ahead and get on your couch or your bed
and sit on your your feet like this and
let your butt sit on the heels and press
down if you could do this if you can't
you can put a pillow between your butt
and your legs but you want to stretch
this and really you're stretching the
front part of your legs what's happening
is you're sending signals from the
stretching to the other part because
they're both on an electrical circuit
and you're going to start to create
relaxation in your
what right here so you do that stretch
and then you yuri rate how you feel and
you should feel wonderful again it's
good for flat feet or anything in the
bottom of your foot any pain in the
bottom of your foot and i mean it's just
the opposite of what people are doing
unfortunately but and it's going to take
too long but this if you do this like
once a day for a week it probably would
never come back unless you have some
systemic problem some arthritis or gout
which you have uric acid crystals in
there in which case you would have to
change your diet get off any sugar eat
more vegetables but given your diet is
good and you do this it's a no brainer
it just will go away and it probably
will never come back ok check it out do
it and put some comments below